I feel that your wisdom would really be helpful
for certain people who are content creators.
Do you?
(upbeat music)
You got famous very quickly.
And I'll say that
as someone who had the same form of success,
I turned into a real animal.
I mean, you know, well, not a real animal
but I'd like to ask how you stay grounded.
You know Drew, fame came later to me in life.
I call myself 10 years young.
When the TikTok is done and the multi-colored furs,
you know, are put away.
What sparks joy for you?
I'm very normal.
What's in the park I think me papa
taking care of my little baby brother.
And, you know,
I will sit back and sometimes watch my own TikToks.
Oh, so you do watch yourself.
I know some people don't,
but I believe in being your own number one fan.
I never knew whether I should ever,
you know, watch my own movies.
I even wondered if I should show them to my kids.
And then eventually they saw some
and now they call them mom movies, which has very sweet.
It's funny, you know,
I haven't shown them Beverly Hills Chihuahua,
which I have to say.
I went into major method for,
I take it really seriously.
Now, the internet can be a very difficult place to navigate.
How do you stay at par the tab?
So, I just got to make sure I space surrounded
by people at home, friends and family.
And remember that it's real life that counts
not what's online.
How do you stay grounded and remember what's important?
I'm still a little lady that works on four legs,
so I'm quite close to the ground to begin with, hi-hi.
That's good, I like that.
(swooshing sound)
Are you on any dating apps?
You know, Drew, I've been single for 10 years
and I plan to keep it that way.
I make myself happiest.
So, why would I leave that responsibility
to someone else, hm?
I have wondered why I've been single for six years
and I am so happy and content
and hearing it come from you,
well it just makes me feel better about myself.
You have impeccable fashion sense.
I'd like for you to give a piece of fashion advice
that we can all follow.
As much as I love my fashion to be fun and flirty.
I always put comfort first.
You don't find tool itchy.
Fun facts underneath all micro dresses.
There is always a layer of velvet to keep me nice and cozy.
Well, that's a hot tip right there.
Okay, Tika as a last question.
At the end of the day, how do you unwind?
How do you unleash?
I see what you did there, Drew.
I have five fluffy pillows to choose from,
so I'll take my time choosing one, get a nice cozy blanket
and then block out the rest of the world
for about 22 to 23 hours a day.
And what is your advice
on how to maximize two hours in a day?
Number one, make your photo shoots very quick
30 seconds to two minutes maximum, eat as much as you can,
bathroom break, rehydrate and then back to bed we go.
Gosh, Tika you are so smart.
Thank you for adding me Drew.
I love these types of conversations
and when powerful women view.
(upbeat music)